Hello, hello.
Hello.
How's it going?
It's going so well, how are you?
I'm doing good.
I'm in the process of moving right now,
so I have boxes everywhere.
I just saw my dog run through the backyard with half a tree.
So it's an exciting morning over here.
Aren't these zoom worlds so weird?
It's like you come on shows like this, you know
before the pandemic and you weren't distracted by your dogs
or I heard maybe your girlfriend might be there.
She is.
She is also with him,
running around somewhere in the background.
The beautiful Madelyn Cline,
who you are in the show with and-
I am.
I love this onset romance.
It's so exciting.
Thank you.
It is.
It's nice to have somebody who not only
you enjoy being around, but you also enjoy working with.
And I'm sure as you can attest to
there's some days where you show up to work and you're like,
"Ugh", but you know, to have your partner right next to you
can kind of pick you up and be a, you know,
a good person in your corners.
It's just been awesome.
And even shooting season two, you know
doing it through the pandemic and all of that.
Yes?
Okay, well no, I'm just so excited
because your show really just broke boundaries
and it was such a phenomenon
and people just latched onto it.
So hardcore.
So congratulations on season two.
Thank you.
And you're shooting it already,
can I have some details?
I'm so excited.
So we wrapped production on season two, about a month ago.
So it's in the can, we're editing away.
We don't have a release date yet,
but you know, we're super, super excited about this season
and treading water with what I should and shouldn't say but,
I'm thinking about it.
Pun intended.
Exactly, literally I'm like, "Uh huh", we're excited.
And you almost didn't make it to your first audition?
There's a story there, your mom,
will you tell me what happened?
Yes, so yeah, I, you know,
I was doing the whole pretend to be an actor in LA
and try to pay rent by any means possible.
And this audition came up
and so my agent was like, "Are you available?"
And I was like, "Sure, I am.
Yeah, no, I'm still still unemployed."
And he said, "You have a flight, in three hours
you're going to Charleston."
And I landed in Charleston and I went to call an Uber
and my bank account had over drafted.
So that was kind of like the bottom of the well for me
and I had to call my mom.
And so she sent me a hundred bucks.
I got an Uber straight from the airport
to the production office and that's where it started.
And then I never went back to LA.
Well, one of the things that I think is so important
about that story is when people see 4 million followers,
on Instagram and this show blowing up,
they don't know the history of the struggle
and it's the struggle itself,
that is something that you're shining a light on.
And I'm so in awe of your mission
and you're advocating for mental health awareness
and resources in schools
and I would love for you to tell us about the organization
Bring Change to Mind, and what happened
in your personal life that made this your cause?
In Bring Change to Mind,
so I've grown up in a, you know, a divorced family,
my mom and my biological father divorced when I was young.
And I always had a little bit
of an imposter syndrome growing up,
not sure where I fit in,
believe it or not I was bullied in high school.
And I always had this anger and aggression
towards not understanding why this type
of stuff happened to me.
And also the anxiety that sort of comes with it.
And as I sort of progressed into, you know, my twenties
I realized that I was still feeling a lot of these emotions
whether it was uncertainty or, you know, just sheer anxiety.
I mean I would have full crippling anxiety attacks.
And so with Bring Change to Mind
they had targeted the exact age that I started
to experience my own battles with mental health.
And so I got on the phone with all of them there
and the lovely Glenn Close,
who was one of the co-founders
and we just immediately connected.
And I realized that I'm doing a disservice to myself,
if I didn't use my platform
for what I wish I had at that age.
And I realized that that was where my audience was.
And so it just, it was exactly what I knew I needed to do.
Okay, so today we wanted to help spread your message
by surprising some students who are working
to bring this program into their school.
You ready?
Mm hm, I'm ready.
Okay, Lily, Kaley and Aliyah
from the Chicago High School for Agricultural Sciences
think that they're here to talk about mental health
but they don't have any idea you're here.
And their hard work has paid off
and Bring Change to Mind
is officially coming to their school.
So Chase, are you ready?
We're gonna hide you.
All right, here we go.
Please welcome Lily, Kaley and Aliyah
from Chicago High School for Agricultural Sciences
in Chicago, Illinois.
Kaley, how are you?
I'm good, how are you?
I'm very well and I would love to ask you
why mental health education is so important
to the students at your school.
It's so important because mental health
is something that's not talked about enough.
Like we learn about our physical health from a young age
and what to do to stay healthy physically,
but never taught what to do when you're in the middle
of a panic attack or when you're feeling so anxious
you can't stop overthinking or those days you feel
like you can't even get out of bed.
Well, I happened to be speaking
with someone who was talking about the very same subject
and I'd like to bring them in now, actually,
Chase, are you there?
I sure am, hi guys.
I just wanted to bring in the one and only,
yes, I see by your reaction, it's Chase Stokes.
(audience applauding)
Hello, hello.
(audience clapping)
How are you guys doing?
I'm doing good, how are you?
I'm good, I'm good.
Listen, I just really briefly wanted to say thank you
to you guys for coming on here
and being vulnerable enough to even talk
about your own struggles with mental health,
not only being advocates for those
who don't feel like they have a voice.
So from the bottom of my heart, thank you guys.
This means a lot to me and I don't even know you
but I want to give you a hug
and I'm super super proud of you guys for, you know
using your voices and doing the right thing.
We have an announcement.
So you guys have officially been approved to bring
Bring Change to Mind as a chapter to your school.
(audience clapping)
Yeah, so congratulations.
I really just want to thank you guys
at your amazing school in Chicago for bringing this program,
Bring Change to Mind, Lily, Kaley and Aliyah
and thank you for everything you're doing Chase Stokes,
you're amazing.
And "Outer Banks" has made a huge impact
and made a lot of people happy.
So look out for the premiere of season two later this year.
Thank you so much Drew, it's been a pleasure.
Thanks for having me.
Hello to Madelyn for us too,
thank you so much.
I will.
(upbeat music)